hi there it's me again remember in
college when you were able to eat
whatever you want whenever you wanted
perhaps a three-day-old sandwich at some
backwash lemonade at four in the
afternoon and you call that breakfast oh
those were the days but now you're an
eighty five percenter and if you think
you're gonna be able to eat with that
type of freedom again well you have
another thing coming
are you guys what what where do you
think you're going
we're going out we got dinner plans no
not tonight we're celebrating your
sister Sarah's perfect SAT score 2,400
only 300 people on the whole planet
could have ever gotten that I bet I get
into every college I'll bet you do too
your mother made tapas it's Mexican well
Spanish but who's counting don't correct
me that's what the book said no Mexicans
not Spanish okay write off the book okay
we're gonna go oh no you're not mister
there you go
try to break your mother's heart hey
Mike here's something be present fine I
would like to propose a toast our dear
sweet Sarah congratulations pumpkin you
never disappoint to our shining star you
are one of a kind
thank you yeah you're perfect ah damn it
well come on Michael don't be a sourpuss
you're special too yeah let me think
does anyone want to bite they're really
good yeah this guy he's kind of like our
comedian remember you used to dress up
in your mother's clothes and dance in
front of the mirror smears face with my
makeup come on you remember this you'd
go around saying I'm Paula Abdul
straight off now tell me do you who I
don't like this see a sport we all like
family stories right Bob it's Rob don't
correct me my doll kissed it up
something fierce he made us do a full
ceremony the wedding I was an eclectic
child he'll say yes this kid had rubber
sheets all the way through high school
no no he wasn't a bed wetter you
understand he just liked rubber you know
some people like thread count this kid
likes its
yeah I've always been like who's got my
razor on stage do us a favour Mike go
put on that dress yes it'd be fun come
on do what your father says go put on
the dress yeah I gotta get out of here
you're gonna put on that dress
Oh after hearing your parents talk like
that you wouldn't be able to eat ever
again are you one of Michael's friends
due to you still living at home with
your parents we're here to help
enter the Comedy Central growing up and
getting out contest you could win rent
for a year presented by KFC original
recipe bites bite sized chicken is all
grown up